muhammad mansarai can't remember the
last time the association for ebola
survivors of which he's secretary
carried out a campaign to educate the
public about the virus
funding has dried up
and just looking after themselves and
their families is quite a struggle
but this is not the only problem
survivors like muhammad face
sigma
still on the ebola survivors family
because some of them we have been living
with them because of this support
you know bringing rice
money
palm oil you know they got supply but
now there's no supply so they look at
them
they look at them differently
more than 26 000 people who are infected
by ebola after the first case was
reported in west africa in 2014
and more than eleven thousand people
died in three west african countries
many of the four thousand people who
died of ebola in sierra leone are buried
here eight years on the virus remains a
threat but because of past experiences
in dealing with the disease experts say
medics are better equipped and prepared
for any outbreak
at a military facility in freetown is
sierra leone's first ebola response
center
hundreds of people were treated here
but in the absence of new cases the
center now handles other infectious
diseases including covet 19.
colonel stephen sivali commander of the
country's army medical corps was part of
the ebola response team eight years ago
we know now what does not work
even if we don't know what works
and
i think we're in a better position than
before
however
i don't think we're out of the woods
during the pandemic big investments were
made in facilities and equipment to
fight the virus but officials say most
can't be used now
so all those infrastructure the
resources the equipment
deteriorated and
we are not able to plug
into
those facilities during the covet 19
pandemic
despite that he says the experience
gained during ebola epidemic has helped
with the covet 19 response
it's a vulnerable group but muhammad
remains concerned many sierra leoneans
still wouldn't know how to protect
themselves from ebola he fears an
outbreak now could cause as much damage
as in 2014 or even more ahmed idris al
jazeera waterloo sierra leone